this is the first red carpet since baby
it is yes I have like about three piles
of Spanx on me right now like how many
things can I put in this dress yeah oh
my god what went into getting ready for
that cuz it's gotta be a whole different
process now right you know it's hard at
first getting me used to the new
postpartum bod and you know I've been
working out a bunch and just trying to
be as confident and good you know what
I'm a mom and I mean I'm a bracing then
new me so it's a baby with you while
you're getting ready oh baby is actually
home with the in-laws yeah in Nashville
but she has a cute little I just posted
on my Instagram at her first black dress
oh it's cute
yeah she's celebrating from afar she
totally yeah absolutely choosing the
name you know what I just I heard the
name Jolie and I just thought it was so
pretty and then raised my middle name so
I wanted her to have a little piece of
my name and her stuff now how has it
been adjusting to life as a mama and you
know your husband I hear he's on diaper
duty sometimes but a good job yeah
husband is amazing on diaper duty he's
an absolute sweetheart he's a you know
extremely hands-on are you appreciating
date night that much more now yeah no I
mean even were like honey we didn't spit
up on us if we look like we're like we
got makeup on so it's bad this is really
fun for us right now
a cm's glamour right I know I love it so
the baby is here what are you working on
next are you thinking about what's next
well right now I have a new single out
cold side know whenever on the road
bunch of birthing festivals and having a
good ol time